my beloved yale family
for the next few minutes please join me
in the spirit of prayer and fix your
eyes
on this vast night sky
center your hearts and let yourself
simply breathe oh
gentle god we look to you for it is you
who places the stars we your beloved
people
from many different families are all
connected
through your creation we all look at the
same night sky
and we are all searching for meaning in
the midst of this pandemic
we long to hear your voice to feel your
healing touch
for we are a people in mourning
there is a weariness in our hearts that
weighs heavy right now
a little over a year ago we had to
separate ourselves from one another
we left our classrooms our offices
our labs our libraries our places of
worship
we left all the familiar places of
communal life
and connection fearfulness
uncertainty and isolation became our
regular visitors
as we began the long walk of loss
and grief
[Music]
gentle god we look to you
we have for so many months had to bear
the onslaught of unprecedented loss of
life
of families facing unspeakable sadness
in unfathomable numbers we have been
brought to our knees
time and again by death by social unrest
the torment of racism and the painful
economic disparities
rendered even more visible within our
communities
all of this has made us feel raw at
times
as we have had to bear the weight of
utter darkness
and yet as we gaze at this vast
night sky we also see abundant light
we see inviting mystery and we resist
letting the challenges we must confront
overwhelm us
as we gaze at the sky we also feel
gratitude gratitude for those who could
not opt
to isolate those who had to go on
to do their work risk their lives to
care for us all
as we gaze at this night sky we see the
light of hope
the promise of healing and restoration
we remember the strength of love
we see something so much bigger than our
individual stories
we see the wonder of creation and our
small connection
to everyone else looking up and beyond
for generations gentle god
we look to you and we are held
amen
you